in game of thrones the great houses of
westeros are the starks greyjoys tullys
aarons lannisters tyrells baratheons and
martells all these families are
important to the story
but some of these plotlines are totally
different in the books compared to the
tv show
especially the martells of dawn
dawn is a land of scorching deserts and
red mountains
of scorpions snakes and oases
dawn has its own distinct culture
because a thousand years ago a foreign
princess called nymeria
led her people to migrate to dawn so
dawn has more equality for women
dornish women have equal rights to
inherit and rule as a man does and dawn
is more relaxed about sex
paramores and bastards and homosexuality
are more accepted in dawn
300 years ago when aegon targaryen
conquered westeros
dawn was the only kingdom to resist him
using guerrilla tactics to escape his
dragons
dawn only joined the other kingdoms much
later and not by conquest but by
marriage between the martells and
targaryens
so dawn has a proud history of
independence and defiance
the martel words are unbowed unbent
unbroken eighteen years ago the king of
westeros was aerys targaryen
and the heir to the throne was prince
rhaegar the older brother
of viserys and daenerys rhaegar married
elia martell the beloved sister of duran
and oberyn martell and their uncle lewin
was in the kingsguard
so the martels were closely tied to the
targaryen throne giving them lots of
political influence and prestige
rhaegar and elia had two kids future
rulers of westeros but unfortunately
king aerys was a mad cruel tyrant and
prince rhaegar ran off with lyanna stark
to have a prophecy baby
sir robert baratheon fought a war to
make himself king
rhaegar and lewin were killed in battle
tywin lannister attacked king's landing
and his soldier
the mountain gregor clegane raped and
killed princess elia and her two
children
elia was going to be rhaegar's queen her
children were going to rule westeros
but all that was lost and king robert
married cersei
so a lannister became the queen instead
of elia
elia's brothers duran and oberyn were
furious and aggrieved they lost their
beloved sister
and her children and their uncle lewin
and lost their political prospects with
the targaryens
ever since they've wanted revenge
against the lannisters
and to get a targaryen back in power
they want
vengeance justice fire and blood
but they don't get it right away the
prince of dawn
is daran martell he's a cautious
patient ruler who thinks carefully
before taking action
duran is full of pain and grief he
suffers from gout
a disease that causes swollen painful
joints
and he still mourns his sister elia
so durant sits in a wheelchair in a
palace called the water gardens
watching children play the kids remind
him of his responsibility to protect the
people of dawn
he wants revenge against the lannisters
but he also wants to protect innocent
lives
so duran won't start a war that he might
lose
tehran plays the game of thrones to win
oberyn is the opposite to duran known as
the
red viper he's dangerous and
unpredictable provocative and passionate
a warrior and a womanizer at the age of
16
oberyn had sex with lord ironwood's
paramore and they fought a jewel over
her
oberyn used a poisoned weapon so
ironwood was killed
which was a problem because the
ironwoods are the second most powerful
house in
dawn to prevent conflict duran gave his
son clinton to be fostered with the
ironwoods
and oberyn went overseas for a while
fighting as a mercenary
studying as a maester and fathering
bastards
all over the world so durran and oberyn
are very different but duran says they
work together closely
he says if oberyn is a viper duran is
the grass
hiding the viper before it strikes
in book two westeros is at war and king
joffrey
needs allies so tyrion lannister offers
an alliance with dawn
and duran accepts princess marcelo goes
to dawn and is betrothed to marry
tristain
duran's younger son marcella and
tristane are young kids in the books and
they develop an adorable
innocent friendship but soon their
family's
feuds threaten their peaceful lives
tyrion invites iran to come to king's
landing and join the small council
but instead of cautious patient duran
the red
viper arrives oberyn demands justice for
the death of
elia and wants vengeance against gregor
and tywin
so in tyrion's trial by combat oberyn
fights the mountain
he wounds gregor with a poisoned spear
but gregor kills
oberyn it's not clear what duran
and oberyn's plan was here but this
attempt at justice
just makes things worse oberyn's death
inflames the dornish people into uproar
they want war against the lannisters to
avenge oberyn and elia
and leading the call are oberyn's
daughters the sand snakes
oberyn had eight bastard daughters by
five different mothers
they all have different personalities
and skills but they all
have oberyn's viper eyes the eldest
obara is a warrior strong and fierce
and angry nymeria is beautiful and
ladylike
but deadly with hidden blades tyene
seems innocent and sweet but she's an
expert with
poisons after oberyn's death the snakes
come to duran
and demand war so duran imprisons the
sand snakes to keep the peace
it seems like duran is playing nice with
the lannisters
people think he's just too weak and
afraid to avenge his siblings
so durran's daughter takes action
ariane martell is prince iran's heir
she'll rule dawn after he dies but aryan
feels that duran
doesn't trust or respect or love her he
never shares his plans with her and
never teaches her to rule and never
arranged a good marriage for her
aryan believes that duran wants to make
his son quentin his heir
instead of her and aryan refuses to be
cheated of her birthright
so aryan starts a secret plot she plans
to crown myself as queen of westeros
as a rival to king tommen to provoke war
between
dawn and the lannisters this war would
give the martels their vengeance and
would position ariane to
rule dawn instead of quentin so ariane
seduces myrcella's guard sir aries
and she and her friends take myself but
she's caught by duran's guard arieohota
sir arys is killed and this emo [ __ ]
darkstar
attacks myself darkstar cuts off part of
myself's face
before fleeing into the desert so
ariane's plosh
goes terribly wrong and it turns out
that the whole thing was
based on a misunderstanding duran
doesn't hate aryan or want quentin to
rule dawn
duran has plans for aryan
it turns out that all this time that
duran avoided war
and made peace with the lannisters he
was secretly planning revenge
he's worked at the downfall of tywin
lannister since the day they told him
of elia duran reveals that after
robert's rebellion
the martells made a secret pact with the
targaryens
to marry ariane to viserys targaryen
the plan was that the martels would help
viserys take back the throne
and destroy the lannisters for vengeance
justice fire and blood but since duran
was so
cautious and patient he didn't want to
risk war
until viserys was ready and had an army
so
for like 10 years duran didn't tell
aryan or viserys about the marriage pact
and iran didn't help viserys and
daenerys while they grew up on the
streets of essos
viserys died never knowing about the
marriage pact
and durant's secrecy just alienated his
own daughter to the point where aryan
plotted against him so duran's plan
failed but now that viserys is dead
duran has a new plan instead of ariane
marrying viserys
he'll have his son quentin marry
daenerys
that way dawn can help daenerys take the
throne and get
vengeance on the lannisters and quentin
and daenerys can be king and queen of
westeros while ariane
can rule dawn it's a nice plan but
like the previous plan it's a [ __ ]
disaster
quentin martell goes on a long and
dangerous journey to meereen
to marry daenerys targaryen he tells
himself
it's a grand adventure like the heroes
in the stories
the young prince and his friends travel
to distant lands to marry the most
beautiful woman in the world
but quentin learns that adventure stinks
his best friend gets killed by pirates
he's forced to join with mercenaries and
to fight in
war-torn astapor the whole journey is
traumatic and
horrible and when quentin finally meets
daenerys and offers to marry her
she laughs cause quentin's nickname is
frog
and daenerys knows fairy tales about
frogs who turn into enchanted princes
for their true love
but sadly quentin is neither enchanted
nor enchanting quentin isn't a
handsome prince charming he's short and
awkward and kind of fugly his
personality
is like his father's he's sensible
dutiful
and dull while daenerys is attracted to
hot bad boys with blue beards like
daario
quentin says dawn will help daenerys
take westeros but
dawn is no help to daenerys now she's
busy trying to bring peace to marine
so daenerys marries his da instead and
then she [ __ ] off on a dragon and
disappears
leaving clinton feeling like an idiot he
crossed
half the world to marry daenerys if he
goes home without her
he'll disappoint his father and fail his
country
so quentin decides to be brave and bold
like the heroes in the stories
he plans to steal one of daenerys's
dragons
and to fly it to find daenerys and to
win her heart
and take her back to dawn for fire and
blood
but it turns out that being a brave
young prince
is not enough to tame a 10-ton
fire-breathing lizard and dany's dragons
burn quentin alive quentin's last word
is oh so life
is not like a fairy tale and another
martel plan
for fire and blood ends in disaster
back in dawn duran doesn't know that his
son
is dead he's still waiting for quentin
to come home
with daenerys and fire and blood
a targaryen does land in westeros but
it's not the targaryen
he was expecting in the books there's
this kid
called young griff varys and illyrio
claim that young griff is aegon
targaryen
the son of rhaegar targaryen and elia
martell
people think that aegon died in robert's
rebellion but varys claims that they
secretly swapped out the baby so some
other baby died
and the real aegon survived and varys
and illyrio have a conspiracy to make
this aegon
king of westeros there are hints that
this aegon
is fake that he's not really elia's son
go watch the varys video but real or
fake aegon could take the iron throne
his army has taken some castles and
tommen's throne under cersei is weak so
aegon asks duran for an alliance duran
desperately hopes that this kid really
is his long-lost nephew
elia's son but duran is cautious
and wants to make sure that aegon's
legit so duran sends aryan to check him
out
after her plot with myself ariane seems
to have changed to have become loyal
and obedient to duran he tells her to
just meet with aegon and report back
to be patient and careful but aryan
still has ambitions ariane feels jealous
that if quentin marries daenerys and
they take the throne
quentin will be king of westeros while
ariane will only rule dawn
will she have to kneel to king quentin
she thinks this sibling rivalry might
lead ariane to take
bold action fans speculate that aryan
might yolo it and suddenly marry
aegon because if aegon becomes king his
wife ariane would be queen of westeros
and she wouldn't have to kneel to anyone
but like every other martel plan this
might end badly it's very possible that
aegon and ariane will take the throne in
king's landing
but eventually daenerys and her dragons
will arrive
and she won't be happy to find a fake
targaryen
sitting on her throne author george
martin has hinted that there'll be
a second dance of the dragons a civil
war between targaryens
meaning that aegon and daenerys might
fight
one character has a dream that dragons
are coming
and everywhere the dragons dance the
people
die so the ending in the books will be
different to the tv show but it seems
likely that daenerys and aegon's
conflict
along with cersei and aerys wildfire
will cause king's landing to burn and if
ariane is with aegon
she'll burn too like oberyn
and quentin aryan's desire for fire and
blood
may end in fire and blood
the sand snakes might also be doomed
obara nymeria and tyene swear obedience
to iran
so duran sends obara with ario and sir
baylon to go kill
darkstar the edgelord who attacked
myself
it's 3v1 but darkstar is dangerous
and he might steal dorne a legendary
magic sword
where warned that darkstar might kill
obara
if ibarra survives she might go to
nearby
old town because ibarra's mother was
from old town and she seems to have some
major
mummy issues because she now hates old
town
says she wants to attack and burn the
city
and interestingly obara's sister sarella
is at old town
studying as a maester at the citadel in
disguise
sarella loves old town as much as obara
hates it
so it could be dramatic if a barra
attacks the city
at the same time that euron and his
apocalyptic magic are approaching
fundamentally obara is motivated by
anger
she's chasing after something she can
never catch
maybe at old town or with darkstar obara
will be killed
tragically consumed by her own fury
meanwhile tyene and nymeria are going to
king's landing
durran wants tyen to infiltrate the high
sparrows sept
and for nymeria to join queen cersei's
council
cersei is about to go on trial for
adultery and treason
and her champion is robert strong the
reanimated corpse of the mountain
gregor clegane who killed elia and
oberyn
the lannisters say that gregor is dead
they
even send gregor's skull to dawn which
raises the question
how does gregor have a head without his
skull
was someone else's giant skull sent to
dawn
or does gregor now have someone else's
head or
some gnarly necromantic [ __ ]
under his helmet
bran has a dream of darkness and thick
black blood
beneath a giant's helm maybe that'll be
dramatically revealed during cersei's
trial by combat
because nymeria says that if gregor
appears again
cersei will be exposed as a liar before
all the seven kingdoms
nymeria and tyene will be furious that
the man who murdered their father
still fights for the lannisters maybe
they'll take
revenge nymeria says that
she wants to murder tommen and there is
that whole prophecy that cersei's
children will die
nymeria will be perfectly placed on the
queen's council with her hidden blades
and with tyene's poison
so maybe the sand snakes will kill
tommen
and maybe myrcella as well in a horrific
bloody act of vengeance maybe the deaths
of her children will lead cersei to burn
king's landing or maybe it'll be dany's
dragon fire but either way
in the flames nymeria and tyene's
obsession
with vengeance may end with their deaths
in fire and blood just like oberyn
and quentin and aryan and obara before
them
all of duran's plans for vengeance
justice
fire and blood go terribly wrong
partly because he's too cautious and too
untrusting
barristan says that iran keeps his
secrets
too well and iran waits too long
durran's first line describes the orange
trees in his water garden
the blood oranges are well past ripe
he waits too long so they fall and splat
on the ground
if duran had attacked the lannisters
earlier while tywin and gregor were
still alive
then maybe the martels could have gotten
justice for elia's murder
but now that tywin and gregor are dead
they can only get vengeance on tywin's
family who
had nothing to do with elia's murder at
this point a war for vengeance will only
cause
more death and suffering oberyn's
paramour ellaria says that vengeance is
a
terrible cycle of violence oberyn died
avenging
elia now the sand snakes want to avenge
him
if they die will their younger sisters
have to die for them
there's no meaning in death having
gregor's skull
doesn't make ellaria happy a skull can't
warm her bed or make her smile
as quentin's friend tells him right
before he gets himself burned
men's lives have meaning not their
deaths
justice can be good but obara nymeria
and tyene's obsession with vengeance by
murdering children and starting wars
can only end badly and aryan puts her
country at risk for the sake of her
pride and ambition
ellaria says that doom and death are
coming to dawn
you can imagine duran sitting in the
water gardens when quentin's bones come
home and he'll realize that all his
careful plots and plans have only got
his family
killed tragically the martel's fight for
justice and vengeance
just causes more injustice and death
sometimes fire and blood only
makes ash
there are more theories and details
about dawn that we couldn't fit in this
video
so we made a little extra bonus dawn
video that you can watch now
on nebula nebula is an independent
creator-owned video site where we don't
have to worry about youtube's algorithm
or demonetization
nebula has exclusive content from people
like lindsay ellis minute earth tiazu
wendover and more
you can get nebula in a bundle with
curiosity stream
curiosity stream has thousands of
documentaries like david attenborough
nature flicks
and the real war of thrones which
explores the real history that inspired
game of thrones
with the link below you can get
curiosity stream and nebula for a year
for just 15 bucks you get heaps of
quality content including this little
dawn video
and you're supporting some of the
smartest creators online
and alt shift x sign up at
curiositystream.com
alt shift x thanks for watching
please like comment and subscribe links
to the artists are in the description
as well as some essays to read more
about dawn
thanks to patrons daniel laplante jake
rosenberg dvorah lynch amber lee on
hellermann
ziki kazan and edith with the man hands
you